die zustimmungsgesetz und systems
beschlüsse der länder zur artikel 1 des
fünfzehnten staatsvertrags veränderung
rundfunk rechtlicher staatsverträge vom
15 dezember 2010 sind soweit sie § 2
absatz 1 des rundfunkbeitrags
staatsvertrags in landesrecht überführen
mich hat die getrag satz 1 des
grundgesetzes insoweit unvereinbar als
inhaber mehrerer wohnungen über den
beitrag für eine wohnung hinaus zur
leistung von rund von beiträgen
herangezogen werden die zukunft des
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunks ist
gesichert auf lange zeit das
bundesverfassungsgericht hält den
rundfunkbeitrag die sogenannte
haushaltsabgabe für verfassungskonform
nur die inhaber von zweitwohnungen
dürfen nicht herangezogen werden in
diesem punkt also sie sehen die
karlsruher richter einen verstoß gegen
den allgemeinen gleichheitssatz
ansonsten aber ist das system
verfassungskonform
das heißt die karlsruher richter
argumentieren wenn 90 sender
bereitgestellt werden die rund um die
uhr empfangen werden können darf dafür
auch ein beitrag erhoben werden
unabhängig davon ob man das konkret
nutzt und es sei gerechtfertigt dass an
die wohnung zu knüpfen das heißt das
argument der demokratie steuer das wird
von karlsruhe zwar aufgegriffen das ist
nicht ertragende grund sondern die
bereitstellung eines umfangreichen
angebots das diesen beitrag rechtfertigt
so gesehen liegt der fall in der politik
die politik hat einen breiten
ermessensspielraum denen sie aus
karlsruher sicht verfassungskonform
genutzt hat man kann natürlich weiterhin
die frage stellen ob wir diese angebote
brauchen ob jeder bürger zahlen muss das
ist aber aus karlsruher sicht kein
verfassungsprobleme sondern die länder
haben im rahmen ihres verfassungsgemäßen
einschätzungsspielraum es dieses system
aufgestellt das heißt natürlich nicht
dass man das politisch nicht neu
aufrollen könnte und die frage stellen
könnte weiterhin nach staatsferne nach
notwendigkeit dieses angebots es ist
aber kein gleichheits problem aus
karlsruher sicht kein
verfassungsprobleme obwohl natürlich
schon sich die frage stellt ob man diese
abgabe in dieser form braucht die
gesetzgeber sind verpflichtet
bis zum 30 juni 2020 eine neuregelung zu
treffen vor allen dingen mit blick auf
die gewandelte medienlandschaft und auf
die frage inwieweit sich der
öffentlich-rechtliche rundfunk
wettbewerbsverzerrend auf die privaten
medien ein greift jetzt auch etwas in
bewegung gekommen also das ist glaube
ich das feld der zukunft das ist auf der
einen seite konzerne wie google und
facebook gibt auf der anderen seite den
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk dessen
finanzierung mit 7 milliarden im jahr
jetzt gesichert ist und der sozusagen
den privatfinanzierten durch werbung
finanzierten medien zeitungen
insbesondere auch im netz konkurrenz
macht das wollen jetzt womöglich die
länder auch beschränken aber das ist
glaube ich das problem der zukunft dass
hier eine wettbewerbsverzerrende
situation eintritt die es früher so
nicht gab
das bisherige recht ist bis zu einer
neuregelung mit der maßgabe weiter
anwendbar
das ab dem tag der verkündung dieses
urteils bis zum inkrafttreten einer
neuregelung diejenigen personen die
nachweislich als inhaber einer wohnung
ihrer rundfunkbeitrags pflicht nach § 2
absatz 1 und absatz 3 des
rundfunkbeitrags staatsvertrags
nachkommen auf antrag von einer
beitragspflicht für weitere wohnung zu
befreien sind